[Music]
welcome podcast all right and we are
live welcome to the iron Lords podcast
episode number 72 and it's another
glorious Sunday and we are back at the
round table and the Lord's Day
we've got Xbox Scarlett cloud spider-man
vs God of War
Bunji Bunji is handling up Forsaken
switch stock and psvr to to discuss so
we're gonna get right into it
so let's introduce the Four Horsemen of
gaming don't use you suspects at the
round table
my co-host with the co most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the how of the young wolf
mommy
Lord addict are you doing sir doing
pretty good uh what's doing get the park
guys going yes sir we have almost a
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single-player selfish experience and
also the sastra darkness
mr. offline profile Illuminati and Lord
patreon of the iron bank mommy
Lord sovereign I do sir don't get mad
doing fantastic a little sleepy a little
groggy but I'm let's move forward I want
to piss that off of course we have the
Incredible Hulk of this aka the excess
gamer oh the lord of combat sports who's
a man of his convictions that man's
nothing less than that premium
experience and is the get money game up
Oh beloved Lord King how you doing sir
guys understand
if you want to know about the combat so
go watch combat though yo I'm gonna be
the clan man my man let me tell you what
these codes stored in these streets
shout-out to Jay Fonzarelli shout out
the tag shout outs and Chris shouting up
to sinister for finally coming back to
the family the family welcomes you with
open arms my brother open cause we love
you um shout out to Hawaiian shout out
to Dino yes that out to Dino we got a
solid squad of clan mates family members
they're running these IOP streets this
Dustin is popping people if you're not
with this clap this this clan your clown
like it makes no sense for you to be
running with people alright and this is
a PSA this is a true PSA if you're in a
clan and you don't like exactly what's
going on and you your and the
leaderboards and you're doing everything
for your clan but your clan does not
support you you gotta lfg something
leave them come to us um you in there
with three or four your friends and you
know you're looking for that of the
other three to get this raid popping you
want to have jokes you want and you
don't have your clan is 50 members
there's only three you you can't find
anybody leave them come to us
leave they'll leave that clan if your
solo dude I cut any streets and you lfg
and anything leave them come to us leave
leave everything and come to us drop
what you doing right now go to your xbox
and find King David OTW now we'll add
you as a friend and then I will add you
to the family this is like roasted on
Ostra get down lay down
let me tell you something how we do it
it is so BC it is so crazy everybody has
to have the black spendy - yes everybody
get that gun you come in that's at the
door shout out to Jeff on somebody we
got it on his one and got the catalyst
on the second run oh and he never did
the jump puzzle before anyone he did it
on the rip or the first off do
rip her got it and it was in it we do
night falls we do night falls and in
five minutes we won phases bosses that's
supposed to be three phases we do range
we run raised from beginning of the
morning from when I get on at five
o'clock in the morning to 6:00 p.m. in
the evening
we're running raids and night balls and
everything all day we check in exactly
who needs what and what knees where and
we'll we at with it all right so don't
ever think that you don't have friends
to play destiny we are here so leave the
clan drop them and come join us right
now get on the later I love it
take over you have to take give money
game out we put the clan master
something all day I'm running with Clan
no doubt radio that fax back and of
course the gaming ninja himself
does she know be Lord spread never
illness in the realm of the ILP not
telling you what you want to hear but
what you need to hear ya salute the King
the clan was absolutely let destiny to
all day like I said sinister Hawaiian
Dino and of course Lord tactical himself
in everybody these spindles like nor
King said I want to shout out our Lord
Frodo who we grabbed up in there
we got him his you know I'm saying I was
real and like I said this mode is just
oh actually we did on excellent
escalation protocol this week none of us
deep and to be real with you I feel it
needs to be a permanent mode in destiny
but yeah I love it so much that it's
just like it's a shame that they don't
have proper matchmaking because like
that mode is amazing like that's what I
expect to see on a patrol but just
bosses and everybody getting in we were
just melting he was out of control
outside of that um yeah but I just can't
talk too much about it but a Master
Chief collection program or I will say
are things are looking very good very
promising like what I'm seeing and I got
talked to solve cuz I in a requena Oh so
I actually touch octo pad
mm-hmm so yeah then open mind jet how
was it
all right the first 10 minutes I can't
front solve it was almost in the bushes
his pushing ways is his drug game
addicting ways demo like I said last
I'll be so you know I basically you know
do that joint on and on so you bought it
or you got the demo no I got the demo
okay okay okay
yeah that's that's a touch you know I'm
saying so you know pretty much in the
demo whatever you know it's it's just
very slow louder
they got voice dialogue before them
nothing you know you press the button
got to let them finish talking you know
say like it's too many button presses
like it's just not fast enough like it
should be seamless and that was just
dragging I'm like I don't know if I
could deal with this you know saying and
then when I got to a certain part maybe
30 minutes in or whatever whatever it
started to heat and I'm like okay and
I'm starting to get the hang of it and
and the the fighting is traditional you
know the 16-bit JRPG turn page so that's
what I like them okay was getting to but
they got the guy I had had some skill
he's a scholar he can analyze you so
like you fight longer and then like even
the okay this do susceptible to fire
this dude's susceptible to this any yeah
you would keep learning like he that guy
I pick has a unique skill even when he
conversate with all the townspeople
analodjica yo that dude right there he
you know say he's stealing or he dislike
it's funny like so I I see why people
are getting into it I'm still not ready
to purchase just yet because I got too
much backlog to be dealing with some 70
hour game right now
I went there to go pick up what does
that date ready player one player one or
whatever yeah
movie right so I go on there and then um
also rampage did oh I picked up rampage
because it's sentimental to my heart
pages right yeah I'll get to the counter
and the lady goes oh you have fifty
dollars and best five bucks you want to
use that now hmm
one copy hello for the free basically
nah um let me check this out oh listen I
see it's twenty nine people watch them
and only twelve people check their life
we had a Roman Lords come on down yeah
man I know what you mean like when you
get the UM you go to Best Buy like they
tell you you've got actually no you know
it's so much dialogue so I'm like I and
besides the dialogue they're talking
their dialogue so that's the other thing
awesome yeah so I like the fact that
they got it but it's just like just
getting through to speed it up that's
all I'll doing some first long down with
the audio I like the audio I like the
audio you don't say it just sounds
pretty much Lord added what you've been
playing nothing past couple days really
you have been Loki okie came with a with
a ray with uh so long you can arrange it
he's an escalation protocol with me been
playing he didn't like what was
transpiring in that raid oh yeah what I
say is this you know we we have patients
when we taking somebody to derail we
came up with a new rule we're not gonna
try to break in three players or four
players when we go to
we're gonna take you to rave we're gonna
have seasoned veterans and we're gonna
sharpen one novice through teeth the
novice ground up that knowledge is gonna
learn there's gonna be a rotation we
take the next novice through if you've
never done a raid and it's completely
brand new to you don't be afraid we'll
take you to it and we'll get you through
everything well we only gonna take one
at a time now those days well we got
everybody's veterans you know we just
run it there's no problem but we're not
gonna take two and three and four that's
what we's doing and we're gonna race for
three hours which shouldn't be right out
yeah I think all right just like you
gotta have you know I feel like just one
noob to kind of bring them through you
know say as opposed to like most people
who haven't done it because then it
really so I gotta stay out of
frustration with that that that's that's
that that's that's for the bushes I did
what we did it three or four times and I
didn't get one single - what the real
issue is and I feel like four times that
I don't get anything and this way I
don't get the boots the good and I'm
like look like it'd be different this
thing is like you know equivalent to
like a POA or something you know like
that like one round as a pou it takes
mad amounts of time to go through seven
rounds like that and you really don't
know anything from it oh it's just not
worth it no it is worthy just were
unlucky but I hear what you saying like
I thought you would like it cuz I just
like fighting boss after boss after boss
I've got me it's cool to do it one time
no it's for this it's the same thing for
the week each week it's like a weekly
reset then they change it up again and
it's a whole new boss
it's a whole net new Saturday but I get
it for your first time and I trust me I
was in my feelings too when we played on
my damn her Neil got the gun you know
say and knows the thing about it those
weapons are powerful there's those
ichael oh yeah they're very
yes DJ yeah we we flawless on destiny
one get home DJ join me right now go to
your xbox and here's a friend
I believe you talking about you we are
going over the message in the box
I'm going over it so basically it's in
the patrol space and a woman on Mars and
it's huge and it's basically all these
different mechanics you have to do to
unlock bosses to then fight bosses and
then keep progressing in these levels to
it it's extremely hard like you have to
be at minimum you know 370 or whatever
360 what let me explain to you it's
killing a bunch of [ __ ] or killing three
crystals and then a bunch of [ __ ] thirty
minutes doing an entire wave all seven
rounds it takes about 30 minutes about
the whole thing the whole thing oh my
bad don't you I thought you bid per
round I was like yo you know AJ Clarence
seven rounds is not an easy thing like
and you to say yo we cleared seven
rounds which we did
this is this the shit's not easy
language is not easy right and I today
I'm sorry I just don't feel like that
you should get this done and I get
nothing for it like you're wrong about
that all I'm saying is you got crazy
unlucky and I understand it drops is
just like you're doing rate if we all do
a rate you're not guaranteed at least
something exactly what he's something in
the rape even if it's something that he
has already at least you can see
progress in one direction or another and
I understand that and I feel that I I
just never heard anybody I've never
heard I got a bomb but I didn't get a
weapon so you're gonna get an armor
piece it's just a getting the weapon
part that I can't agree is some some
respect that you know maybe you should
get a guaranteed completed this is like
some of the hardest in-game content in
this game it it's just like the orange
ease all messed up like I would agree
with that I would agree with that
I'd add I agree I feel that after
especially when we rent the second or
third time we should at least got
something weapon wise we did all get you
guarantee something armor wise you just
got to check maybe you didn't realize it
was it was that your body stores there's
no vendor for the thing so bring up the
halo he did talk about the halo what it
is yeah I guess he can't really go into
like I say is is it's very promising and
I'm I'm very excited I'm very excited
you don't say looking going forward but
too late oh my
I like games that that I purchased and
he's still constantly upgrading them
when they think everybody do it in a
bush I mean upgrade them because it was
at the floor ground when it came out so
so Master Chief collection
halo-halo the Master Chief collection
was such a letdown for me I don't care
about that game but it was it was
someone in the chat don't understand
like this is my like when I come on here
I speak for my I don't care about Talmud
or like I know I could talk about it I
will let you know that you know the fans
wanted to know anyway lassie folks and
the people have spoken to the question
with the recent article by Eurogamer on
the state of crackdown 3 development
what do you think xbox should do in
terms of its release the winner at 49%
in a fairly convincing 4-way ILP poll is
the crackdown 3 February release is fine
the delay is ok group coming in that's
in place at only 25% was too shallow
Lords crackdown is a free game cast the
vote was move crackdown 3 to Scarlett
group and in a close last place at 12%
was to scrap crackdown 3 entirely it's a
mess group
let's start with Lord sour who so what
do you think about this
sour there's no money one of my monitors
I don't have to answer now what do we
think about this whole thing cracked it
the people are gold I'm shallow you know
what you know what it is we crack down
it's like we said before I think there's
too much pressure on there's getting to
be something more than it is and I would
have liked them to expand upon what you
know the crack down formula is and if
they do it's in-game pass I think all
the big game fast games that have come
down the pipeline I've purchased because
of either you know getting early access
or extra stuff not crack down as the one
that I'm probably not gonna purchase
separately I'm just gonna my game pass
play and if and you know if it's great
great if not oh well the second place
you know say so it was what it was you
know the people he definitely just want
the game to come out without the delay
and then it's people that just say hey
it's in-game pass you know so what so
anyway that was a post stay tuned for
the new hours that's dizzy
alright so hurry let me answer this game
anybody that plays with me in the
daytime knows that I'm all this weight
loss thing
um I adopted the water diet right which
consists of drinking gallon with two
gallons of water a day and having one
meal so all day long I'm drinking I'm up
to three gallons of water a day and I
mean one mil then the results is
ridiculous it's crazy
so right now you just caught me drinking
my water and I put also on Twitter
what's inside the water which is
phenomenal it's just nice water so no
craziness
whatever stay tuned for the new people
in the show so let's get into these
round Table Topics your king we got some
scarlet stuff going on in these streets
what's happening well right now they're
talking about dropping two systems right
and they're talking about dropping a
system well this is the rumors these are
the rumors that's how handy streets and
they're talking about dropping a system
that is a traditional system with the
disk drive hard drive CPU processor
everything the whole shebang
and that's normally how everything goes
but then while Jews came out that
they're trying to drop a streaming only
system now the only way I could see that
actually happened and this has been
coming out with new information that on
the streaming system itself which will
probably be something really small but
it will have a CPU probably inside a
hard drive that you know I expected to
have a hard drive and probably a ppyou
for processing as far as like barriers
and stuff like that so you all floating
most of the stuff and the graphical
stuff is being done in the cloud yeah
my question is is this history repeating
itself with Miss mix messaging and is
Microsoft dividing the groups before the
groups even get a chance to form you
know Tony we already know the
playstation 5 is one way mm-hmm we know
from what we've heard that it's gonna be
gonna have the rise in chip it's going
to be a traditional console again Sony
is very clear with their path in
PlayStation 5 from what we hear so far
right but what we hear when Microsoft so
far is very convoluted very what's going
on am I going to get a streaming system
people is already saying if they do that
I'm out but they have a traditional
system or why are they doing a streaming
system so my question is Microsoft
setting itself up for four by dividing
the fan base and having them in fight
with all of these rumors and they not
clearing anything up because they said
the Scarlett is gonna have multiple
skills
all right fumes are you all right let's
get to it um I'm gonna let low attic
start before we actually let them jump
in let's clarify a couple things right
so from what we know right did the two
excuse one will be a traditional
physical hardware and then the second
one will be kind of like a dedicated
cloud streaming device like a low power
device right it'll be a low power device
on that King said um you know the
question is with latency especially in
the United States right with internet
speeds being what they are so the the
argument there is that they've figured
out some way to offload from some of the
bottleneck that usually occurs in
something like that to actually have
good powerful fairly powerful hardware
in the streaming box that offloads that
stuff locally so it just focus on on the
GPUs of being pushed on the cloud so
you're not doing everything so pretty
much it's not gonna have the internals
of the entire physical scarlet but it'll
have some device some things inside of
it
you know that the input image processing
and collision detection because don't
seem to be the things you know at least
that kind of hinder gaming right create
that lag right so that would be in the
streaming box it should bring the price
down ultimately of the shipping box
correct it'll probably be more expensive
than your typical screaming bitumen box
it'll be more expensive than it you know
then an Amazon look fire or an Apple TV
or something like that or a Roku it'll
be more expensive than that because it
will be actual fairly powerful hardware
in there but again like you know $200
that's a pretty huge thing and then so
again so just to understand from the
people who just trying to get in the
news like so pretty much a portion of
the game is going to run locally with
the shaming one and then the Xbox clouds
gonna kind of splice so basically for my
understanding its to the game's gonna be
running in two locations at the same
time and Microsoft clouds gonna kind of
stitch it together with the dedicated
stuff for the controller inputs and
stuff like that in the device to kind of
really help alleviate the lag why don't
I don't really see the game running in
two places at one time more so that like
again the compute stuff is gonna be
happening locally the game will be
running on a server somewhere to your
you know drive machine but the rumor is
enough
the rumor is that the game will run in
two places you don't say that right
you're right because I did hear
something that basically the small
smaller the the scarlet cloud will have
the ability to actually run the game at
low settings so consider low settings
for a PC if you wanted to run it locally
you could run it at those settings right
just locally on the machine yeah I mean
it's this is pretty interesting stuff
this is uncharted territory obviously we
all have you know our feelings on on
memory so let's start with low attic
because um what do you feel in today's
question as far as like them splitting
up to skews you know having a physical
one do you think that's gonna confuse
the consumer base and for you personally
how interested are you in either I don't
think it's not even rip I don't even
really think it really matters the
internet side of it I mean that does
obviously in the target you know
people's connections I
think that streaming is mainstream
enough in gaming right now to even like
try to come out like maybe if Google or
something like this up till now like you
know what the Nvidia show its and stuff
to do it but besides that you don't
really have a whole lot of streaming in
general when it comes to games they are
Nvidia has a couple different streaming
method right I don't think I don't think
it's popular enough to come off the
shelves like that mmm let me ask you
this like what do you feel about okay
xbox call it reveal you know they put
out the two SKUs and let's say you know
for argument's sake Xbox Carla
traditional is 500 right and then they
come with that 200 pricing points cause
they you think this is a mistake tell me
why I look at me up in I don't think her
people are gonna look at the the
traditional one before they look at that
you know the the streaming one like I
don't know part of me feels like the
Internet to a lot of I can't really
speak on it so I know how the latency is
like like if the Lightning sees good and
it's not an issue there's gonna be a lot
of people to pick that up over it but
like at the end of the day like isn't
that plan that's a Marcus toast main
objective mmm systems what's gonna come
first and um there's some rumors about
that as well you know I'm saying that um
yeah I now see what you said get me
thinking Steve I just don't think we're
at a position with anything really like
I don't think that the even even 20 22
years from now when it's not only 20
maybe but like I said like it's I don't
think do you think that as of right now
let's say that the music industry
because obviously every industry is in
the streaming but yeah that's pretty
much how it is right yeah pretty much in
do you think if they would have just
jumped it was like okay like we're gonna
give you a box that like I just don't
think we're at that position like if it
was a little bit
lately look what happened the moment
they announced it Twitter blew up so I
don't like that I don't want that and
that's just the minority you know the
people on Twitter but you know these
people are the ones telling their
friends well that's not gonna work like
I don't think it's socially acceptable
enough to play games through a streaming
device yet I just don't it's something
Damini is just that if they're if
they're talking about this like it's a
reality right and if you heard other
companies talk about it yeah you've
heard Ubisoft talking about like this is
this is the future my thinking is that
they figured something out that we're
not pretty
look I could tell you once ins to
completely debunk that 2013 was the
future - and look how bad true but can
we also make you me and we're there
right now there's a lot of games of
service games going on but like I said
at that time digitally was not
acceptable the internet lashed out and
they lost an entire generation I drank I
think the messaging was more the problem
than that it hasn't been formally
announced but they have they made a goal
in which you haddock he's like yes have
they came out and made an announcement
like debunking this or anything like no
not at all and then I got they're not
going to this is from a leak so
absolutely well I get that I get that
but you know at the end of the day like
I'm not gonna say this would be as bad
because they there is an alternative
right but if that alternate is $500 I
don't see it being good for them what
are your Sony jobs I've heard people
that I won't name then are confident
it's coming out at 500 hmm well if it's
coming out of 500 what price was the ex
be like like if the ex is 199 and that's
and then the stream
is $2.99 it is defense you know shout
out the Lord J Fonz I've seen a couple
people's you know a very anti you know
scarlet cloud skill you know they're
just not the scarlet like thing but like
at the end of the day how many people
are going to get a streaming ball and
and that's another thing that I don't I
don't like the direction they're going
is like I don't necessarily I think this
mid generation thing is going to make
concerts here going forward weird okay
which way because now we're gonna have
this next Xbox come out as that mean
like the ex takes over with the the the
s is at the moment it's like so so are
they gonna start developing for three
platforms at the same time like these
are good questions the is that that's a
great question to does does the this do
G or the s now become obsolete because
me as Ava's talked about this we've
talked about to some previous I appeased
and at some point there's a physical car
like you know Jess has an issue with
them making games for the windows at the
same time that's not even necessarily my
issue might is like are we gonna be able
to get games that really do something on
the X because they're making it for the
s2 I mean the X that was my whole issue
like everybody probably thought this
week that King jumped ship and switch
sides and he's in Tony camp King is a
stony sympathizer
concern it is when you have a
Playstation let's say two years into the
next-gen with Sony's making games only
for ps5 and they're still making games
for the X like five years after it comes
out hold on hold on to that door what
you just said is when we do the PSV our
topic I got some news to break on Mac so
hold on to that that's a good talking
point right there solve let's get you in
on this man well what do you feel about
the two SKUs it is first of all how do
you feel about the Xbox call it cloud in
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay all right oaken there is no way the
X becomes the base model CPU jump alone
makes it impossible you're probably
gonna be able to stream games to your
SRX but to run them natively you'll know
that need the newest hardware or I saw
so I need your opinions on it sticks to
Scarlett cloud and does this confuse the
basis it confuses the base if they
continue to do what they've done which
is be funny with the messaging they have
to get better at clear messaging that
one thing is one thing and one thing is
another thing once they are trying to
create funny language around the stuff
then you start confusing people in it
and it looks like you're purposely
trying to confuse people right because
you're hiding something and that's
that's something that they've been
accused of in the past and rightfully so
you know you have to be very clear about
this messaging especially if you're
trying to sell people on two pieces of
hardware at the same time in you have to
be clear about the base console the home
console being your traditional console
powerful console I do see see it being
$500 if we're talking about doubling the
GPU in in the X and a serious bump in
CPU you're not doing that for less than
500 bucks you're not no in order to
alleviate that narrative a little bit to
me if you're talking about a cloud
streaming device it's like I said they
would not be talking about this in
earnest
they didn't figure something out
that rift why would they be coming to
the table with the same thing that's
been failing for 10 years already
why doesn't make any sense talking about
anything the leak comes from a source
that has been it has been pretty good in
the past right so it's fairly credible
too and again everything they've been
talking about it makes sense that this
would be something today they're doing
and again and by separating it right
they do alleviating the mistake they
made with with Xbox one and 2013 words
that they've forced everything on using
force to connect on you they forced the
digital you know actually writes in a
DRM everything that was the difference
they're giving you options they just
have to be clear about the fact that
they're giving you those options you
can't you know give some weird
convoluted message and people like I
don't know which one to buy now I don't
know what this is right you can't be
your right elbow yeah actually this
would you in any chat I think the
message is good let me jump in this is
this is interesting you know say cuz
when I first heard it you know you know
I had some reservations too I mean I'm
you know come on King and I we don't we
oh geez all most of us here on the panel
and on you know we're just not used to
hearing that right and we've seen the
pass of you know what which glitch cloud
screen gaming looks like you know I'm
saying so it's far the fact that as long
as they have traditional contract
console I personally don't really have
an issue right that dad loans the
old-school way to play games that's it
now I will say as a techie I'm
purchasing both day one i'ma had first
one in the in the living room and I'm a
had a scarlet cloud in the bedroom and I
want to test it I want to see cuz
there's some of that's very appealing to
me like the other thing called dreaming
is gonna come out before the main
console I don't know I I can't say if
that happens I don't agree with Reuters
so my thing is this like I think of a
world where it's like okay you know we
love our switch right but at the same
time we know we're not gonna have that
graphical fidelity of
right so I'm thinking about we go to e3k
solve a little box you don't say like
and you just go with you now the issue
is gonna be a hard time getting on
facebook at castle of the lords we did
this PlayStation bro Charlton Lord say
him with a chat you know say all I'll LA
connect but um yeah man like that I just
thought about work it hurts them time
let me switch don't get me wrong but it
hurts I'm like damn I want to play alone
right now I want to play a little you
know whatever right now so that part of
it is very appealing for people who have
strong in it for those who don't have
strong internet data caps this is not
for you that's how I look at it you know
saying but I will say it is tempting if
they come in with that 150 to 200 and if
some of that person fits the criteria
where they have you know a good inning
internet you know stuff and you know
they will in because most likely sorry
that they're gonna but you're gonna have
to buy some type of subscription service
but have those gains and know that the
make you know let's see how this thing
works the best way that this could work
out for them yeah they're not to contact
these big you know providers yeah and
they're gonna be like we'll give you X
amount of money
mmm but this device doesn't how to get
your data caps right they could if they
could figure that out they've done
exceptions like this for like Pokemon go
Nintendo literally had miners or use
Pokemon go it didn't use it or dad your
dad at all
that's what's up that's a huge deal also
refer to do exact if this is my feeling
it if anybody could do it
it's gotta be Microsoft right they've
been pushing it 2013 in the world and
setting up data service all this time to
focus from Saatchi and numbers cloud and
then let's be real now let's be 100%
practical real mix it for whatever you
say that latency it's not it's pretty
much does not exist that's what makes me
hard to stream on Twitch cuz I'm just
like damn you needed comets come in late
today now the ultimate test from me is
like a game like a desti and only online
multiplayer game utilizing resource I do
want to ask you guys a question
let's go what's the point in getting
something like an ex because you know
damn well you ain't stream in 4k or on a
streaming device wait wait wait
apparently accordance shout I gotta get
my crew are DX dealing them apparently
the Davidians is doing that they got
lazy I have purchased it on every form
that the wittiest builders came out the
last form was the tablet that I that I
thought was going to be the switch
there's a lot more power than dared to
take me to there's a lot more powerful
than the switch they that's this is why
I thought the switch was gonna do it
when I see when I played the demo of
Resident Evil 7 on their joint only
thing that was different was the
resolution but the graphical detail was
there man I was streaming from Japan
mind you cuz the service was there it
was running decent for it the little
piece that I got of it you two are gonna
are gonna stream off that thing one time
like nah I can't do this play the
original you're gonna play whatever
their next stuff is I'd be like yo this
looks amazing then then play that it
looks like it like an excerpt was like
yeah that that's what that peasant s is
for me you're gonna go ahead and
downgrade the stream so why you consider
it at a bit rate because remember most
likely this stuff is gonna be based on
your data capacity right your home dated
like I do dye my files honey
illustrating highly doubt regardless
book connection yeah it's gonna look as
good as a native system I don't I don't
know that too we know with the whole
when we get a native 4k ultra blu-ray
disc and when you when you stream like
okay snapping on PlayStation they don't
have a native 4k mojos in the chat oh
one play on the X 2 in the X and s and
stream box it's not complicated games
will scale to each console stop
spreading fear and information that's in
his defend let's be real up into this
area defense prior to this point game
streaming has been relatively a joke you
know I'm saying it's not something
viable you look at PS Marlowe look at
past you know it's just not it's not
been gone I can't say that because y'all
don't play the shield the shield
actually is really great but there's
like hardware in it that's the thing to
shield ya know right and that's the
difference between that and all the
streaming stuff that's before like King
and I know we bought on live day 1 on
live with Aloha it had nothing in there
except oh and discreet ooh looking soupy
and Vaseline
oh yeah I still got mine and I look at
it every once in a while like oh it's a
jumping-off point you learn that stuff
that's why I sincerely believe that they
have something figured out that we're
not necessarily primitive I was gonna
finish my point so I'll say one last
thing I want this is why first of all
I'm a techie so I'm excited about this
stuff I'm like mix stuff is this just is
this the streaming device just for game
pass because I have heard no I find
everything for my understanding it's
gonna be for everything you know
everything that's why Luka you know she
didn't even cover because we literally
don't know nothing we had to spec you
Microsoft isn't making a comment for us
tonight like you don't like my Soph said
y'all correct but like lost I've said
the rumor comes from a very credible
source right so I believe that this day
is some true a lot of truth going on
here so all I'm gonna say the reason why
I'm excited besides fact I'm attacking
all this other crap the thing is I look
at Microsoft and I feel like they don't
get enough credit for the innovation
they push in the console space each
generation I'm saying look at the OG
xbox right first I'm not you know Xbox
Live it's like they're either the
trendsetter or they take a Trent and
take it to the next level yeah you got
Xbox Live you got they had eat that with
og - Ethernet in the hard drive in the
Box custom music soundtracks 360 one of
the best you eyes arguably the best
controller party chat system was all 360
right Kinect debut in 360 then you got
Xbox one digital services it's not even
close and I said game sharing playing
who's here cross play you know saying
they took the connect to the next level
devices like disconnecting this thing
does - I got you I got you
you know say so it's like they've done
all these outstanding things you know
I'm saying what with it on PC so
just excited if his mother if it bombs
right at it if it's the worse or it just
they still haven't solved it you still
got the traditional console you still
got the classic way that you play games
all I'm saying is it like like what
Slava saying it if they're thinking
about this that means that confidence um
thing out in this Rubik's Cube of cloud
gaming for them to even think about
going back at it again that's all I'm
saying I mean I get a little skeptical
undercut like you know what we were
talking about earlier like are they got
to start like you know having this
streaming service and mine when they
develop games now like yeah these first
party studios from Microsoft's gonna be
thin like to the max just handle one
thing we got a this big way I get our
minds can't comprehend it right and I'll
let you guess we haven't seen it like
again the closest thing we have to what
is rumored that they're doing is what
the shield is doing where you have
hardware locally that helps push that so
it the experience is much improved to
what we've seen in the past right so my
mom and my only thing is this and you
know my penchant for for thinking that
both you know Microsoft and Sony want to
get that switch money and that portables
so what if this scarlet cloud is small
enough you could just throw a screen on
it and make a they well according a Phil
member Phil statement at e3 was that
they want this service on all devices
talking about if you think about it
right the Box still requires you to have
a television regardless to what you have
to be in a mall set up is the imma give
I'm gonna give you the king grand plane
to his all me no only begotten Son I
think it's going for North it I think
let's be real right when you look at a
market like Japan you know they're not
buying as much the traditional consoles
it's smaller spaces you know the mobile
gaming rocks out there right now if you
have this service because let's be
people talking about oh I don't have
internet but look at the mobile sea
you're using your phone data to play
games right so if they're able to get
that service on to these devices like
full that's how you get into markets you
not strong blow up on a face
I believe when you breaking ground in
any direction and you're gonna hear it
you know yeah you're gonna be the first
one to take the flack of it and then you
know slowly let's let's let's keep it a
honey you know Sonia is always biggie
back door for somebody else's footsteps
they've always walked in somebody else's
shadow now maybe they might shine
brighter because they try to you know
act like they're innovators with it you
know that's they crowd base but they're
not they have never actually been the
first in basically anything then I can
remember don't say they first console
with CD because PC was doing CD they
chosen horse the DVD player into the
house in our houses to push the system
was a failure people like how am I
supposed to trust Xbox to make a cloud
streaming console when he couldn't get
the cloud to work for crackdown three
city destruction we don't know what
crackdown look like boss will come
or anything Microsoft don't even know
where to look like oh we we run in this
topic into the floor speculation let's
finish the up less bottle up on
everybody's bottling this up because you
know listen at the bottom at the bottom
on this whole thing
Microsoft is not gonna invest in
something that they don't see will bear
fruit you know yes you can sit there say
whatever those what no phones was decent
it just didn't take off because you had
to juggle knives beating the breaks off
these new I guess so genetic to is it it
bombs right it's an option what are you
gonna buy I'm gonna buy I don't even
know if I'm buying a next-gen Xbox at
this moment but you might not buy Xbox
so you're not gonna play with us what
it's it's like that like looking from
the perspective that's happening this
generation like people always thrown in
on the negativity not the positivity
which is what you're doing that's what's
gonna happen let's say the streaming it
does great you know it's gonna get a lot
of good reception but let's be real it
could go just the other way just as easy
it goes bad and then that that that
traditional console is gonna get
overlooked because everyone's focusing
on the bad brother right on this point
and it ties in a sauce point if they
don't get the messaging down if they
have a repeat of 2013 and no one really
understands what this thing does it's a
wrap right there has to be separate help
but yes it's not being it that's good if
nobody you can't use it without it
doesn't work without like that pissed
people off the shelf that PlayStation is
dead
would do a king what it is $200 and it
does perform as as intended that's a
game-changer 200 hours for a next-gen
system but it'll say that's crazy
say that you know do you guys think if
let's say the ps4 comes out if the PS
file comes out at 399 now the streaming
thing comes out at 199 and the next Xbox
comes out at $4.99 do you think that's a
hurt
they of our perception of the brand yes
it will streaming device that's cheaper
than the competition I really think
they're gonna try to get away with that
like I really we do have a console for
you that's cheap you go you Wilin out
that's not fair I can see both put both
of y'all points I definitely see I can't
see Phil no fundamentally and this is
this is where strategist comes in he
fundamentally understands that the price
point was absolutely the biggest problem
they knew they listened you gonna tell
me they didn't know this only was coming
in the 400 they know what Sony's gonna
be coming in price point wise that's all
cute doll dude we're just gonna have to
see this could work out great and if
they have no good marketing no good
communications with the consumer it's
gonna blow up and they face well shut
out the Lord man's game will kill me
sobbing um he said in the day what games
they drop don't matter what my xbox does
cuz they don't want the games at the
moment so what to see that point as well
but King you want to wrap up your topic
they got us all world my I wrapped it
already
[Laughter]
very exciting times you know very
curious about these rumors how it
happens let's move on to the next time
Lord addict sales battle what you got
so I've been seeing a lot of trend on
Twitter that a parent a lot of people
don't know who's gonna win like their
overall let's say month month a month
the first month Agharta war in the first
month of spiderman the game coming out
September what sells better alright solo
song which guy I mean I think you use it
first one to overall would be more
popular um I think overall garda war
stopped at spider-man regardless yeah I
mean God Wars had a lot of time on the
market already um I think what
spider-man has over is that the God of
War is big to PlayStation gamers
spider-man is big to everybody
so spider-man has that ability to just
sell gangbusters especially when they're
able to make it an event release this is
not third party releases on everything
they have a special edition console for
this so the fact that spider-man has
that wide appeal I think is gonna help
it a lot
I don't again if if if it's coming out
and you know early reviews are like tens
like God of War then it's I think it has
the ability to just to blow up I don't
even think if it comes out with it could
come out with the same reviews is gonna
do it for the whole
okay I don't care spider-man is going to
sell like gangbusters
it is a game all right
I don't know I know you love spider-man
you
Oh God
when you let them go when you let them
go I say go ahead at all he said get
your foot off no I say spider-man is is
it going to get out so by what did God
award do in a month
I got oh man it was pretty wasn't I
think what is I'm crazy okay by month do
you mean that month that it released the
month of release that month that it
comes out remember you gotta remember
God walk him out April 20th you had
eight days left in a month okay fine go
get that work have the entire year and
it out sells everything let's get the
criteria of what the Benjamin so it's
its first mom sale so when the MPD domes
out after surpassed 5 million
in the first month oh I got a surprise
that first month sales we got
PlayStation brah we got the Lord brah
he's in a chat he would know God awarded
five million in a full month that is
straight from PlayStation brush so
basically a spider-man has to surpass
that whatever's left in the month right
is that we're bundle I'm not doing that
if he's willing to put his convictions
on the line like I said if King wins
like I said you bet me if you forget it
no bet bet I'm waiting oh he's waiting
all right so if he's confident that
spider-man's gonna win so why aren't you
confident God awards money
I don't know I mean to be honest when I
first heard just to the roundtable and
I'm like God was such a peace right you
know NPD but I can't find you know
salute you know Lord X but you know he's
a big spider-man guy those guys will
cross fire and stuff and they were
talking about it it just seems to be
getting it's just so much momentum that
I'm seeing the suits and the other thing
that has me is I can't front that Pro
bundle yo you know saying with that read
like that's the first bundle I seen on
my y'all think about his game that comes
with the bundle doesn't care doesn't
count
I know week that because that mattress
could tell clear that up with us we had
them all in the remedy that you know
whatever if the system if the game is
packed in
actually we're gonna have to reach out
the math Patel and get him on when you
bend the knee the best part is I'm gonna
Lord Obi you see this is this see listen
Lord sovereign look like needle will
attest it it I can fill with you a
million times it don't matter how many
been the knees have you want what are
you talking about listen you are one of
those people that are free you're free
somebody challenge you know about listen
right now you're going to become the
best mean that internet has ever seen
you know why when I take a picture cuz
the t-shirt is gonna happen I'm going to
have you on your knees the t-shirt I'm
gonna have somebody screenshot that and
I'm going to have that picture and I can
go straight that same day and print out
at least 13 that you going to be the new
bend the knee that shirt exclusively do
I you wanna I want their name you are
going down and it's gonna be so much fun
because your face is gonna be mortified
when I knew listen this is the problem
what you don't understand is I have no
fear of loss because the greatest fear
is not doing anything all right so I'm
going to so much editing on this podcast
in October you have no I
you say I'm gonna be a meme and I'm just
gonna pop up wait when they say
spider-man sold 7 million spider-man has
50 years of fans know spider-man game
has ever had this much attention if any
game can top gata war it would be Spidey
like Santo BER says September slowly
time a spider-man game was good
a lot of she's gonna remove what is like
oh there's a spider-man come out in
September well the last eight I played
has been trash I'm sorry oh you ain't
getting my point brethren Pontus or
vacation can't argue about this all the
time so I want to bring this to the
round table you know since e3 we go talk
about that destiny forsaken talk so in
secret with all the barracks
Game Informer coverage revealing Kate's
death the question is this I'm gonna
bring us to the table is Bungie making a
mistake by showing too much inside
coverage of the game more than three
months ahead of release but start with
Lord adding are they messing this thing
up I wouldn't say they're messing it up
I felt like they know that it's been a
bad year for destiny
and I feel like they know that they lost
a lot of their player base mm-hmm
you know they got a lot of it back over
the past couple weeks which is good but
I do feel like they know that look we're
asking $40 for this well we got to make
sure that these people are so oh I do
feel like they're there they're saying
too much mm-hmm I think they're scared
if they don't say enough you and say
okay now here's the thing like when I
got to defend my man lordy Bonta say his
point is he's like yo but you know I can
get you know I'm Shawn but he like first
thing he was very upset about the cake
were you upset that they showed that
like he felt that that should be I
should have been revealed in story or do
you think like the shock value of is
actually leading people to actually
purchase a forsaken look about it let me
explain one thing to you that there's
nothing that that sells something more
than a famous character dying and no one
misses out on the finale because they
know someone's dying
why don't we every season so you know
there go people are gonna want to know
Kate's probably been the most charisma
person in Destiny's since launch Thanks
he's literally safe taking thing cool is
great I love it yes so him dying like
had a lot of people like and what even
that it was brew and it was like yo they
didn't kill my man cave now people won't
wonder why he was killed
sometime don't pick up that story just
to find out it's a good marketing okay
and what have you gaming for my stuff
cuz I know one of them not stay away
okay so you just been smart and you've
been key okay okay I got you
I don't really mess with Game Informer
in the first place God you follow him
what do you feel about that like how do
you feel as you know a person who even
know Oh
[Laughter]
like a month straight when it came out I
mean I was in there everything is the
robot just clarify this sounds like you
know Nathan Fillion everybody knows with
it they did the right thing by bringing
that out first like this there's nothing
like negative narrative around the game
when you surprise people with something
like that and let's say for whatever
reason like the gameplay doesn't live up
to what people want it right they're
gonna focus on something like that being
surprised by something like that um
unless of course like the payoff after
you gets killed it's um some huge thing
so I think they were worried about
people having just a negative reaction
to seeing that in game so they wanted to
get that message out there and you know
hope you know they're still like if you
look at from like the other perspective
let's say that they didn't announce it
right they let you find out in story
right it's better to tell someone before
story starts so they'd be curious um
what happens do the hypes already
starting to die down
okay died you find out three days after
the game comes out and it's like oh I
know the ending now I don't need a buy
it like I guess one of those things like
to me they just stay 100% sure how
people would react and they decided to
do the same thing and make sure it was
out there so that people could focus on
the other stuff in the game all right
they they Loki they were like yeah we're
gonna tell people he dies and if we did
too much of a bad guys won't bring him
back back and and in terms of like
talking about the other stuff in
forsaken so early for me if they
continue to do what they did with
whisper of the worm leading up to the
game like within the next month if they
I think they said that all the new
exotics will be appearing before the
actual drop they say well they had a big
trailer right now - right chunk there's
no come from you just yet they're gonna
show all of them but there's you know
they've had some history of doing stuff
like that but I heard it's some of them
at least some of them are appearing
before Forsaken actually drops right if
they do what they did was - without ever
made em so where would they appear
no they just talk about their video yeah
they would never drop the exacts before
the Forsaken content what if they
wouldn't know the only before release
that is confirmed is a lot changes that
the destiny community complained about
when they went to Wendy two went to that
new weapon system right not having be
able to have a shotgun and all that
stuff and energy slot and you know howdy
one was they actually bringing that new
chains if they were gonna save today
buer forsaken like a week or two before
forsaken releases so people can get used
to the new weapon shapes that is
confirmed that's the only thing coming
so stuff like that again like I was
talking about whispers worm if they do
something or maybe now what things are
addicts they already talked about what
if they do something else would you know
the next in you have August left right
you have a month left before this right
so yeah they continue to do stuff like
that that's brought everybody back to
the game or at least the hardcore back
to the game I think the fine I think
they find North King you've been
following this news you've been playing
a lot of oh let me let me let me stop
you right there so um what I do with my
information as I lean on Chris no
illness oh yeah hash tag follow Cali
realness and on Twitter um he's a high
powered clan mate and I lean on him for
every last drop of information like you
know inspect my inspect you know that's
that'sthat's his motto so his model is
out there getting all the finest clothes
and letting you know where to go and
what they do having tea for that's like
LeBron James and Kobe oh yeah it's the
completely beast with it um so I listen
to him for information I told him to
also be on flashpoint with you a million
times
he's been explaining to me I've have
literally not watched any video I've
made sure I don't watch anything and I
get little leaks here in here from him
what he explained to me he watched the
video of the other day and he saw a lot
of the guns a lot of the armor pieces
he's really hyped about some of the
stuff that's coming out and on what
stuff look like like I played at e3
I played the gambit mode I thought it
blew me away
I'm totally sold on it I was sold on it
to begin with
but the gambit mode was incredible if
you like escalation maybe fun and
friends it's just really nice um so as
far as they didn't overload me because
I'm one of those people that I don't
want to know too much I like to
experience on my own so if I hear
something through friends which I have
been hearing because a lot of people
have been watching these streams and
stuff like that and that's what I
learned a little bit of it and I believe
you're chill with the spoilage I just
want to see it I can wait to September I
can get it for myself but most of the
information I've heard already from
blank you guys and stuff like that so
you know Kali realness is the one who
actually been putting me throwing stuff
so no I have not seen anything okay so
in your opinion you know you don't feel
this is a mistake you feel this is
something necessarily had to do or you
feel like under North like what's your
whole feeling about these reveals no
like - what is great I know I think
y'all are already used to it um they
have gotten y'all used to set little
packages up for you guys to follow a
little trails and and are showing you
things they if they know how to build
curiosity because they don't really go
too much into what the weapon is doing
and what's their perks they show you the
weapon and they might show you a
screenshot and these people are stop a
screen shot and look and see what the
perks is or not talking about it so it's
like these they are masters at building
anticipation for something and what we
wanted was our taking King in from every
account from everybody is this is the
taken King this is the DLC that we've
been looking for and the armor what I
hear the gear talking about you won't
even be needing the old guns that you
have read random right so no I think I
think they're doing it just right
because the anticipation is at all-time
high drop in that one like father said
dropping that sleepest mu2 or men
yes it just steamed it started like like
this this progressed it just brought
everybody back and I mean you hear
people like you see different videos up
every single day about how they did this
how they did that like no that's that's
what brings this community together man
I mean cuz you what you can do with that
is you can take you can take a weapon or
some armor whatever that by itself is
whatever like it's not a big deal when
you create like a narrative around it
like oh man do this with to get that and
then just it makes people excited to go
back and play the game absolutely get
because it exactly is now you seeing all
this stuff and now it's like damn I
gotta stop playing destiny again before
a new joint come out let me jump in and
I wrap it up so yeah pretty much man
ain't like Isis out there but I won't
pick over them cuz I I love mess that's
my brother you know we do that
flashpoint talk are talking he's
passionate by and I get it
and he's not all the way he understands
what's what they're doing you know his
whole thing's I had to reveal case deaf
no day and they showing so much excited
what are we gonna get the game well is
they gonna be anything new that we don't
know like I get him we don't say and I
definitely wanted to reflect his stance
correctly I think for me and my always
to him is like look man they've got no
choice this is do or die for this
franchise anthems coming division to is
coming you know I mean so they've got to
get the crowd back now so the only thing
I've seen which is different is I've
never seen stuff so much pre hike three
bucks a head usually you get that pre
month the DLC drop September no III show
a little something but come like and you
know like top of all this is where you
start really normally like when taken
care that's when you start to get the
information blast we're getting that now
like July
like since table July we've been getting
non-stop but I think it's smart first
what a marketing team is outstanding
they know how to show off things well
they nada get you poke them do taxes
high you much like a forty second video
got people look shot look shout out to
the Lord addict look at gaming addicts
channel he did a reaction video you know
say it was a raw reaction for the first
time when people see that that's what
I'm seeing in the community and then
what does that do that makes you excited
to actually play the bass game again an
exotic where if you slide you like
you deflect off like projectiles so I
think they gotta show stars guys so this
way people know yo I gotta get it look
what they do when they doing this they
doing that I am it's very clear I'm
saying so and in with the story aspect
yeah it's a little shock value with the
cave thing but I think you know many
people I've seen on Twitter soft say yo
we gotta get them to show who did that
to my maze and the whole story is kind
of like a Western Western you got ten
names on the list
that's who kid okay we will mark this
barren off we get to Aldrin and we gonna
find out what the rate is and all this
other stuff so I think the marketing is
genius
I think they had to do it is generate
nation look at what's going on in the
community right now and I say if that
didn't happen I don't think it's the
same I don't think you know this fever
rush that everybody has right make no
mistake they needed to that's me to was
a laughingstock out here in the game it
was just terrible like people you know
and look at one last point I want to put
shout out to UM Lordaeron Jackson who
said it best he said even if you a
destiny hater
right he said the trailer the market is
so good the bus like solid res he's a
destiny hater he be clowning me all my
Twitter are you still playing it and I
forgot one oh well my son I wanted to
know or just the gun word destiny come
right back so that's my point it shall
do but let me broke ain't none person
nor solve next topic every now and again
you have a slow news week and you have
you know you got a dig for stuff you
know so it's some dirt on the switch so
let's talk about it alright
so industry analysts or not a game
gianna this a Wall Street analyst named
Atul go yeah he works for his analysis
for a company called Jeffries who's
somebody who's commented on gaming
before specifically Nintendo and he's
been known to be fairly bullish about
Nintendo's ability to stay strong in the
market who their stock price to be high
and to sort of maintain growth
throughout the lifecycle of the switch
which is a difficult thing to do to
maintain girls and not Plateau
um but he's recently changed his
projection saying that he thinks that
switch is gonna plateau not have this
exponential growth that he had initially
thought and he's cutting I kissed the
projection for the stock price right and
he's attributing the the cut in the
stock price number to the fact that he
thinks which sales are gonna plateau
right so we talked about this was it
last week the week before about how he
thinks which sales are gonna be just
fine and to be clear I still believe
this I think when Pokemon comes out when
smash comes out especially Pokemon I
think sales are gonna be crazy
now one thing I do sort of agree with
about the plateauing of it to a certain
extent is this we are a year and a half
more than a year and a half into the
switches life cycle there's been no talk
yet of switch 2.0 all the next revision
right and I think that's something that
if you look at what they've done with 3d
s and their and their portables in
general a year out after release you're
already seeing a revision of these
whether it's you know improve backlight
battery life whatever smaller fixing
things that in the initial design people
deemed to be not perfect and they
haven't done this with switch yet and I
think they need to do that because it's
like they're positioning it really
really as a home console that it's one
thing they're not gonna make big changes
to it but it's not really that switch to
me the switch is a portable consoles it
has home capabilities that's what it is
and you need to you need to you need to
push it forward the way you would a
portable system which is what they've
done with the 3d yes and they haven't
done that and to me like if you you know
for somebody like me for somebody like
you for something like
kingdom you gonna even consider another
switch asked if we consider be more
powerful that's when you talk about the
next switch that's what I want to see
right right but one thing that they
haven't done is they've had they not
addressed how they plan to move
everybody that's on 3ds to this platform
they haven't talked about a smaller
switch that's more kid-friendly that's
maybe not modular they haven't talked
about any of the stuff and it's so weird
because to me you know the rumors about
the that is a dumb move we've talked
about this nine times out of ten if we
talk about the switch it's neither Lord
kognito Lord sovereigns Toby King this
is spin doc did you he was he was
supposed to just drop the whole stock
thing we're supposed to talk about the
stock thing but he tried to sidetrack
you and move you away from the stock
part and talk about they should be doing
I don't want you know this this
disestablished with this topic making
you think you're not going to set up
switch in in wow that's gonna appeal to
me unless it's more powerful than the
one that I have so the only audience
they haven't touched it is that they've
never like I said from the start like
that 3ds is gonna kill them more than
anything else and they're not going to
drop that
the day regardless which you guys wanted
that say they promote this more as a
console than a handheld they're really
gonna come out with a straight up so I
know the 3ds Pat ability will switch
it's gonna be his own thing it's only
because the majority of the market see
this as you know a you got a portable
Wii U all your games the gravy train is
over brother
all your Wii U games that you stole from
the other library it's over anywhere new
3d S appeals to me if it is if it's more
powerful than a switch I don't know why
they're making a 3d is because they're
making Pokemon on the switch and looking
at the 3d are still as you know more of
kids in devices because there's people
like King and there's a lot of people
don't are not gonna buy that child a
switch does it breaks too easy people
forget yeah we look at it from the you
know the Western perspective but they're
looking at it firm you know they're
looking at a ward why but they make so
much money in Japan off the 3ds so you
know it's like the only thing I can say
some it's almost like when the ps3 came
out it was hard to kill off the ps2
because the ps2 which is so dominant you
know me it's just one of those things
that a victim of their own success Inc
maybe little backlash was the last ps2
game like think about that cuz you like
okay stop talking to those people and
just let them die already
[Laughter]
you know to do what we want you to do
nice yeah we got a shout-out relevant
native man for that cow milk approaches
I'm done
yo let me judge how much you want to bet
like next year we're gonna start seeing
like a Majora's Mask remake for this one
use all the styles are gonna go to the
gank you said they're done with the Wii
U but they're not they still have Mario
3d World
I'm not concerned Pokemon smash come in
[Laughter]
with a little rematch the little
Vaseline off of it we got to do we
listen they don't like we're gonna give
you this character and tropical alphas
affecting the numbers but you know the
stock returns I got to start announcer
stuff otherwise people that's a good
point
sovereign Luigi's mansions coming up for
the 3ds and not to switch I think this
has been Red Planet's right that in
there
so also have you wanna get this going
wrap this up on your own join the
freaking you know stock prices again
everything is based on fear and
speculation so stock stock prices until
until they coast up is coming as
politics but I don't know what kind of
astronomical sales numbers they had in
mind for the way that it's looking don't
be surprised if they make that same
Pokemon game next year coming out for
the 3ds - we'll see well we know that
this one is that it goes down a
full-fledge in apparently you know it's
supposed to be a traditional real I
meant that one yes very much so I
wouldn't be surprised looking this point
we can't put it back in techno but they
do need to announce new stuff otherwise
stockholders are not gonna be [ __ ]
they gonna put in inside that 3ds is
gonna have the location track is gonna
have all that stuff your job and asking
for inside that switch so now you can do
Pokemon go on your three started off all
we said pretty much the same room is
going around you know a pretty pretty
good authority
you know psvr to you know say it's
common and he said you know it's some
really juicy tidbits right now and yeah
it's pretty much saying this thing could
go wireless
that uh you know something they want to
be up to speed with the new arm with the
competition is definitely supposed to be
an upgrade from the existing ps2 r1 and
they actually gonna have make it easier
to support room try
and a lot of cool features you know I'm
saying that the the current one can't do
as well as like I said Wireless being
not tethered and I'm an upgraded I am D
rising trip as well so there's a lot of
stuff going on with this thing
resolution or bump as well image quality
so it seems that you know Sony will be
most likely gone and doubling down on VR
and the rumor is that um you know in
coincide with PlayStation 5 we may get
an announcement you know a PlayStation
experience one of those things in
reference to that or do just could save
it for later to launch and cause so to
the to the roundtable what do we feel
about this and um you know is it like
Tamar King's point sometimes like do you
think maybe this is a waste of time or
you know let me jump off first of all
let me give a shout out to the realness
for hitting me in the DMS with this
information
no you shattered to the bone yeah you
know no not the realness to find it
sorry fine yo name I do apologize the
finest put them in real cool down.this
respect on my Christmas is stuck in my
head about to get on some destiny but um
shout to the phone is four minutes to
the table and I want a shoehorn this in
this topic and this is an extra topic
that we shoehorn this in now first
you'll hear it live on this I'm selling
my PlayStation VR played my PlayStation
VR and probably six to seven months um
and it's because I was really pissed off
with what they did when they pulled out
the the new VR they slipped to do the
doors you know they upgraded my VR that
I purchased and didn't have a buyback
program for the other one that I spend
that bread on mom now they look like yo
they throw in the whole joint in the
bushes and they come in with this joint
and they like yeah it's gonna be the 4k
and the wireless heading and with the
PlayStation 5 I hear that they have a
chip on board to work better with the VR
um and I guess that works that way I'm
just gonna keep my VR games there and
after I see if it's viable if it really
works and out you know buy the machine
but I'm officially um giving a go down
the game stop and take this VR and it's
out of this house Wow bushes but my
thing is does the prospects of the new
one with all these new features and not
being tethered that doesn't even excites
me when I when I read the information I
was excited by it I thought that it was
a step in the right direction
my problem with Sony is is this right
that this is such a niche thing and it
has a small fan base is the fan base of
it is not large you understand a lot of
people don't want anything on a face so
um yeah like you know a lot of people
really don't think that the enclosed
feeling of it some people got vertigo
there's a lot of problems with it that
they have to get over the hurdles of it
so a lot of people don't like it I think
in my opinion I don't see the sales
figures for Devi are so I don't know
maybe they made a lot of money off of
the VR and the way that they marketed
and sold it but I don't see them really
any streets pushing a hill and you
understand right now these psvr double
dip Edition will sell less than the
regular psvr the casual walkers VR has
moved on already and the majority of
dudes buying the double definition would
be the same guy they might win a song
but it's too little too late mmm that's
how I feel I'm going to take a looksie
I'm going to keep my VR games but the
hard way is out the door and if the
other Hardware comes in and it's really
good and they have games that can
actually take advantage of it and i'm
what i he'll blame right donated a drop
some new avi art is supposed to be crazy
that could be a crazy I got a hell blade
for Xbox I'm not buying it ov you know
you said the resident always right yeah
but the resident the Resident Evil is
the vast blame addition because they
resolution gotta be God body like they
saying but
oh and it's funny I'm cooking low key
defensive iographer not to be Agha but
um no I mean I got chance to play for
the first time shout to say Irish
rebellion games yeah I like some simple
game my first time doing a PlayStation
VR and I liked it was a simple game move
the ball around up hills down hills
avoid traps I was like okay cool I can
do this I'm not gonna be sick anything
like that and I actually liked it look
cool you know as far as the tech itself
it sounds pretty quite like the fact
that it's not tethered though that's a
huge deal to me
you know Sam now and in fact that to be
honest let's give Sony some credit we
always kill them King as far as
peripherals go like they they don't kind
of stay committed and technically
they've not staying committed to the
first one but at the end of the day this
is upgrade this is like the new joint
you know saying and I like what they're
trying to do to it the also thing that's
a big point that I want to get out to
you that I found out and again shout to
game TechRadar you know I'm saying with
the article they ran is that during this
information where PlayStation VR to what
came home is Sony patented a plan for
backward compatibility zuv from a huge
library of over 150 plus VR titles they
got right now and they still got like
106 change coming so it's my assumption
safe to assume and if they gonna launch
PS 5 with this and they doing backward
compatibility for VR solve wouldn't you
pick it's safe to assume that
PlayStation 5 will have backward
compatibility if this would make sense
that the philosophy carries over right I
mean I can see how they could just they
figured that the market for peers VR is
it's small enough that you would piss
the people that work there the other
thing off if you tell them no you can't
play these other games on the new one so
it makes a lot of sense to do it for VR
but at the same time it also makes a lot
of sense that you carry that philosophy
over to your big things and I can't see
them doing black with compatibility for
just a VR game and not just for that
if you won't play your old games get
that PlayStation they've got a huge
library out there you know a ton of
games are still in development you know
saying and I mean even though you know
I'm not a big VR guy I can't my see
myself on or $300 peripheral you know
I'm saying but you know if they got a
dedicated based on ICP shot to j-bar I
see a lot of still rocking with it and
dedicated to it you know it's just me
that will never replace the traditional
experience I need a controller I'm not
trying to have that thing because you
know what it is so you know what it is
King attic remember if you remember with
y'all first I'm picking up steam and I
believe it was a Time magazine article
and they had the kid with his arms out
with the arms a disrespect to all my V
all of that try and I was I'm so happy
that I got a chance to catch footage of
him trying I know you're not gonna buy
something like that book when you did
try it was it a enjoyable experience for
you it was experience I would say it
don't my eyes up a little bit on VR like
at the end of the day like it's
something that's cool it's like III it's
cool to do one time but it's not
necessary it's just like a 3d movie it's
like it's cool but it's not a necessity
like I have to get these glasses and I
have to do this every time you know for
the joints right and it's just like I
said I mean the other of the main hurdle
is always what the Kinect kind of thing
raaaah which is the base is
automatically separated right you know
I'm saying automatic people are not
gonna have it so
developers you know now a Playstation
case needed market leaders so they got
momentum they're the only person in this
space you know I mean Xbox is not in
space so they have some advantages that
can help them but you know you're asking
devs to not make money from a big
portion of the base that doesn't have
the peripheral oh shut up boss moves he
said forget VR tales of Black Tiger
would be a game-changer well the people
the game industry people learn you can't
interfere with the classic controller
monitor setup you try every gen but no
one ever sticks with that's where I'm at
with it King you're right Stan nobody
really about the VR to be honest with
you I tried to champion it you notice I
tailed off of it yeah it was me shouting
into the wind and people like shut up
you notice I didn't cover any I didn't
talk about any we are at all because you
know I walk past the Sony Vaio section
the lives was minimal news really didn't
care for it and the games look do you
know what I'll do to Kazan yeah he's
funny you said that he threw when I was
going when we first got in there and um
you know I'm rushing I've got a game
I'll try to I think the Spider Man I'm
trying to find a spider-man both ways
but in spite of me like well yeah a
bunch of reps or like hey I got you this
despite emember know this is VR son oh
no no no I'm good please what people
waiting last year
you couldn't get into VR like you had
the schedule ahead of time right this
year you won't present you you wanna try
this come on no I know I just leave me
Toto hold on anchorman
important announcement there'd be
something relative you better not say no
fallout or no but that's there or we
mine keep in mind there anchorman was
good you just gotta it's gotta be
fallout 76 you got it yeah that's good
do i okay with the rumors of a second
Xbox garlic cloud skew being discovered
how confident are you that Microsoft can
resolve the latency issues generally
associated with cloud gaming a not
confident cloud gaming will never
surpass traditional console gaming be
confident
Microsoft appears to be on the right
track with the right tools with scarlet
cloud or see I don't care all this power
to cloud talk is just Microsoft version
of Skynet that is those tomorrow you're
the world you're gonna get took over by
Master Chief's it's gonna be epic
yeah so that's what we got right here
you can say that like subscribers a lot
of stuff going on links will be in
description and a local box with a
novelist you are imma chose Lord addict
where can I find people finder and what
do you have going on you can find me on
Twitter the Twitter the Twitter but you
probably are
Lord I saw Opie I will be streaming on
the the twitch channel for iron Lords
podcast today probably around 500 you
know follow the iron Lords podcast
Twitter I will be tweeting whatever you
know that is live definitely come
through support you know especially you
know I will definitely be
playing something dumb I don't know
where stream team we got it we got a new
member which was working on I'm trying
to recruit load old-school-style stream
team so I need you you know saying law
and I think Lord Lord son I'll know
and he said reach out to you we got to
get him on he's interested good dude
I've seen a couple of twitch streams
he's been doing it for a minute would be
a pleasure to having a team so can we
make that help I'll definitely look at
that and you know definitely support
that appreciate the I think we had up to
like almost 60 people in here I
appreciate everyone for coming through
you know we're definitely we got some
announcements uh I'm security I've been
and put in charge of the guest for next
month so I've been doing that oh I got
some good stuff coming for you guys and
I've it's been a see next week no doubt
no doubt
of course Lord saw was gonna want you
we're gonna find one I would love to be
on Xbox or Playstation but I don't know
I was it tough yeah I'll be on that
switch playing hollow Knight Lord King
that combat talk dropped what else you
got going on well just say you know
combat talk is up you know you can see
the real information being dropped and
how fights are really talked about from
an analytical standpoint and the
breakdowns and why I'm so accurate Diane
you know yeah the breakdowns of the face
with me shut up in the corner shut Amira
Quentin was mortified you bend the knee
with or key but we are we are moving
heavy in in these streets to be honest
with you and I really appreciate all the
support from everyone stream team
moving and it's beautiful thing jumping
there streams like following subscribe
get on Instagram if you want to check us
out out of pocket or in pocket oh what
you man it's crazy the Facebook
promotional page that's up and Twitter
when you follow us on Twitter you never
know where i'ma go with certain things
because I start our fire and I dip out
the room and I just see exactly what's
gonna happen with that fire um t-shirt
game we waiting for a couple more things
we have a lot of artists working on
stuff know we have logos and stuff being
done hope you know what have been the
knee segment no popped up today and
really to be honest with you is gonna be
fun I'm just gonna be making it for me I
will not actually have your image on
other people's back um that would just
be for me how we turned he said I
wouldn't I would never do that to you um
I just want you to feel shame with me
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you're not gonna wear what you say I'm a
brother to take a picture you crying
going please join ILP high in Lourdes
podcast on Xbox where we at
Wayne clan on PlayStation because it's
not really social with it's our nose
going on over there throw those guys in
the bushes well we have like 12 people
in every chat and we have another 12
people in the next chat we're jumping
from chat to chat making sure
everybody's getting everything done
shoutout to X by 4 for
listen the squad is growing as people
that you know as gamers as you gain with
thanks we really gain we don't joke
about gaming or talk about game and not
to really gain we really gain with you
so join us you don't have to join no
patreon do to gain with us you don't
have to spend that no paypal to gain
with us
mmm game with us now this is what we do
clan is first if you're not part of our
plan won't whispered word $20 join the
clan just to get whispered warm and you
leave the clan come to you won't pay $50
don't leave they put my child absolutely
late today man so much fun like silicone
clucking said you got a combat talk is
up on the channel parts 1 & 2 the man is
a boxing aficionado he understands
everything and has been acted with the
predictions no flashpoint this week this
past week because the box is on vacation
will return when we get back also check
out all I got in the new trying to get
ILP preview started my little series
started back up again the first one was
the indie game called stay I got a game
coming up once the embargo lifts I'll
get that to the ILP channel ace I'm
working on something please check me out
please report and I'm saying and yeah
like I said everybody stay tuned for the
audio that stuff will be up later on
today and the poll will be up tomorrow
if anybody got anything else you can
enjoy your Sunday we good now we're
gonna has just got to say it's gonna be
a pleasure came for you
[Music]